ja sowieso schon viel zu viel hin und
her in dieser krise für das auch der hin
und her minister steht heute so morgen
so hören wir mal rang
hinter jetzigen lage sehe ich keine
notwendigkeit zu einer verpflichtung
nehmen aber im wahren der bereitschaft
zur solidarität
um andere vor einer infektion zu
schützen und das ist dann ein gutes
signal es ist ohne zweifel
eine nachvollziehbare maßnahme
masken den büroräumen zu tragen aber
genauso wichtig und nachvollziehbar
finde ich es wenn keine partys mehr so
stattfinden wie wir es jetzt auch am
wochenende wieder gesehen haben erstens
werden wir mehr tests ermöglichen um
infektionsketten früher zu erkennen und
zu durchbrechen impfen und testen
alleine reicht nicht um die dritte welle
zu brechen für den jetzigen moment
jedenfalls halten wir die preise
beschränkung nicht für angemessen und
verhältnismässig zuerst einmal geht ja
seit februar märz tatsächlich die
verpflichtung zur quarantäne bei
einreise aus risikogebieten
verpflichtung dass keine bitte so eine
staatliche anordnung durch verordnungen
der bundesländer und in dem moment wo
klar ist dass vollständig geimpften
übrigens nicht bei null aber doch
deutlich deutlich reduziert ein
infektionsrisiko für sich und für andere
haben ist es eben auch möglich
beschränkungen aufzuheben es war immer
klar für diesen herbst und winter
braucht es weiterhin schutzmaßnahmen wir
müssen auch weiterhin im alltag vorsicht
walten lassen normalzustand wird erst im
frühjahr frühestens möglich sein wenn
keine neue variante kommt ja so der hin-
und herr minister wie wir ihn heute
betiteln bild vize paul ronzheimer ist
bei uns im studio paul ein titel der zu
recht da es plötzlich hin und her sparen
hat dazu geführt dass er auch in den
beliebtheitswerten abgesagt ist
gleichzeitig muss man aber sagen der job
des gesundheitsminister war wohl in der
pandemie noch nie so schwierig wie zuvor
deswegen finde ich kann man das nicht
alles auf jens spahn abwälzen ich habe
das gefühl dass dieses corona
kauderwelsch zum corona chaos führt
immer mehr denn das ist ja nicht nur
ersparen der das tut oder der das in den
letzten anderthalb jahren gemacht hat
wenn wir uns andere politiker wie den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten herrn
kretschmer anschauen der dann erst zweig
ausgeschlossen hat jetzt sagt wir machen
zweig wenn man darüber spricht dass erst
ausgeschlossen wurde dass schulen jemals
geschlossen werden und jetzt steht das
möglicherweise wieder zur debatte und
nicht zuletzt die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vorher
glaube ich jeder einzelne bürger in
deutschland angst hat dass da wieder 13
stunden geredet gelabert schwadroniert
wird dann am ende irgendeine schlimme
regelung für den eigenen alltag bei
rauskommt auch die soll es jetzt wieder
geben also man erinnert sich an die
dunkelsten tage der korona pandemie und
wundert sich wie denn vorher die
politiker alles ausschließen konnten ja
nach bild-informationen soll diese bund
länder konferenz nächste woche
stattfinden angela merkel hat ja bereits
sozusagen uns schon wieder eingeschworen
auf einschränkungen zumindest für
ungeimpfte was erwartest du von dieser
konferenz ich gehe davon aus wenn man
die kanzlerin hört dass sie starke
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte vornehmen
will wir sehen das ja auch bereits in
nachbarländern wir sehen das in
österreich zum beispiel da wurde das
bereits beschlossen wir sehen dass in
einzelnen bundesländern wo es bereits
passiert die spannende frage thomas die
ich mir dabei stelle ist wie reagiert
eigentlich die künftige ampelkoalition
darauf dass die regieren werden scheint
ja so gut wie sicher und was vor allem
macht dann die fdp denn das ist ja die
partei die früher in der opposition
immer für die freiheitsrechte gekämpft
hat und auch gegen die diskriminierung
von ungeimpften zum beispiel wie
wolfgang kubicki der das auch heute
wieder getan hat bei uns sind bild also
das wird eigentlich die frage sein kann
sich die ampel koalition schon dagegen
stemmen oder zieht merkel durch und
eigentlich ist es ja auch gute sitte
dass man in den letzten tagen einer nur
noch geschäftsführenden regierung keine
fundamentalen entscheidungen mehr trifft
die dann die nächste regierung betrifft
ich habe das gefühl dass die kanzlerin
das so ein bisschen dann auf den
notstand wieder beziehen wird und
argumentieren wird also die zahlen sind
so wahnsinnig hoch wir müssen jetzt
etwas tun sie wird dann versuchen die
ministerpräsidenten einzuschwören und
man muss ja dazu sagen da stößt da
keinesfalls nur auf taube ohren wenn wir
uns anhören dass markus söder schon
gesagt hat ja auch er einschränkungen er
wird zweig auch er debattiert über die
dinge wieder man hat so ein bisschen das
gefühl markus söder konnte es kaum
erwarten dass die zahlen wieder hoch
gehen dass er reagieren kann und sich
wieder als harter mann präsentieren kann